hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the video World Blitz
Championship 2022 and Magnus is leading
the tournament by half a point and the
only person standing in his way to win
the not only the world Blitz
Championship but the the world
everything Championship as Magnus is the
reigning world classical Champion uh he
just won the world rapid championship
and now if he beats another he will be
the world with champion and he will uh
wield the three titles once again uh for
the for the third time which is
absolutely incredible he he he did it in
2014 and he did it uh in 2019 and now
will he be able to do it again let's
check it out uh if he wins he wins the
title for sure no one can get a job to
him he has the white pieces and no this
game he does not open would be three in
this game he opens with E4 saying okay
now let's uh let's play good chess we
have E5 viable satrov uh last year as a
world rapid Champion Knight to F3 we
have Knight to C6 and the bishop to B5
Agnes goes for the Royal Lopez A6
morphe's defense Bishop to A4 and Knight
to F6 we have Pawn to D3 and now Pawn to
B5 with Bishop to B3 and Bishop to E7
saying that this will not be a quick
draw Magnus really wants to win the full
point here we have A4 B4 and now Magnus
castles now this is all uh top standard
Theory so nothing new being played here
castles Knight beat to D2 and now Pawn
to D6 we have C3 and Rook to B8 by Abdu
satro we have Rook to E1 and now Knight
the A5 putting pressure on that Bishop
so Bishop to A2 and now Pawn to C5
strikes in the center Ponte D4 Magnus
does so as well B captures B captures C
captures C captures on D4 we have Knight
back to C6 now putting pressure on the
D4 pawn and the position has been
reached a few times at night the C4 has
been played a couple of times H3 has
been played Bishop to A3 has been played
but the move that that Magnus place has
never been played before Magnus plays
Pawn to D5 and it is now as of move 15
or rather 16 that we have a completely
new game night the B4 goes after the
bishop and the bishop the C4 of course
Magnus wants to keep his light Square
Bishop that is your most prized
possession in the uh Rue Lopez Knights
the H5 and now Ponte A5 Magnus grabs
more space on the queen side uh Knights
the F4 and now Knights the F1 at the
standard Knight maneuver we have Bishop
to G4 and now Knight to E3 attacking the
bishop here Bishop H5 and now Rook to A3
very nice rock lift The Rook will also
uh possibly be shifted to help out with
the attack against the black king we
have Queen to C7 developing the queen
connecting Rooks and now Bishop to D2
here a very strong is Bishop to F1
because black wants to play F5 and with
the best of the F5 you no longer have to
worry about the Knight guarding the
bishop so Knight it does control the F5
square but okay after Bishop to D2 up
the Saturn does not take advantage of
this he doesn't play Pawn to F5 he plays
Bishop characters on F3 Queen characters
and now Knights the C2 going for some
trades here and now if Knight captures
then the bishop is no longer defended
that's exactly what Magnus does Knight
captures Queen captures and now comes
Knight to E3 also Rook to C3 very strong
but Magnus has a different idea he
attacks the queen goes after the F5
Square Queen to D4 and now Rook to D1
now threatening all sorts of discoveries
for the moment you don't have any but um
decides to move the queen to C5 as it
comes with Tempo but it only seems it
comes with Tempo after Queen to C5
Magnus just plays Knight the F5 now at
defending his rook and A3 attacking the
bishop on E7 and also preparing some
very nasty threats against the black
king So Bishop G5 H4 pushing the bishop
back Bishop to F6 and now Rook the C3
attacking the queen and it doesn't
really matter where you put the queen
but abdusaderov decides to boldly grab
the A5 Pawn as it really doesn't seem
like The Rook has any useful discoveries
but nonetheless Magnus finds one he
plays Pawn to G3 attacks the Knight and
now uh it doesn't really matter what you
do now the brilliant thing about the
Knight retreating to G6 is that it's um
you can take advantage of this any any
way you want but I'm just going to show
you the coolest way look at this
Knight's the H6 check and okay you don't
want to capture because then Queen
captures an F6 Bishop captures on G7 on
H7 and you get checkmated so you might
play King to h8 and say okay that's a
silly looking knight on H6 but then
Knight captures an F7 with the check and
now look at this Rook captures Rook to
C8 with check and now you definitely do
have a good Discovery Rook captures
Bishop captures Queen and black is down
too much material so another big figures
this out and plays Knight captures on D5
now he says alright your Rook is hanging
if you capture then I might have some E4
ideas attacking the The Rook here with
the bishop and Magnus says I'm not
interested in this just moves The Rook
to A3 I will however show you uh what
happens if he captures on D5 because
it's beautiful look at this Ponte E4
attacks the queen and the rook and C3
Queen G4 now says all right I'm gonna
put pressure on the black king here and
just Bishop captures on C3 so what would
uh be White's best reply here it's a
hypothetical situation but even I
thought it would be a nice pause the
video moment so feel free to pause the
video here and try to win this
hypothetical position for white while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
very very slow and quiet move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook the C1 now after this
move there is nothing black can do and
black just resigns the game you cannot
keep defending the uh the G7 Square end
that the bishop cannot remain here
blocking the path of the of White's dark
Square Bishop towards the black queen so
here regardless of what you do you
either win the black queen or you
Checkmate the black king so
congratulations to everyone who found
this but Magnus of course not eager to
over calculate plays Rook to A3 now
comes Queen to C5 and Rook the C1 now
continuous harassing abusatros queen
queen to B6 and now e characters on D5
now Magnus is just up a piece and Abdul
Saturn has to figure out how to win
something back he plays Queen to B2
attacks the rook and the bishop here
rooked the D3 and now Rook F to d8
regarding the D6 Pawn but just King to
G2 magnets first gets his King to safety
before going after that the D6 pawn
queen to B5 attack will put pressure on
The Rook Here and Now Rook the C6 going
after the pawn and there is no defending
this now Abdullah can just hope for a
miracle he plays Rook to E8 hopes to get
some e for Action in uh but just Knight
captures on D6 also guards the E4 Square
he does play e for Magnus just captures
it and he was in this position on the
Move 38 that another back abdusato
resigned in the game and Magnus not wins
only not just that he wins the game not
just that he wins the title of world
Blitz Champion but he is now the world
champion of everything pretty much uh
video organized of every time form at
the class called the rapid and the Blitz
World Champion he's not a world official
random Champion but um that's uh that
that's a different story but yeah he
resigned uh you you resign here you're
down a full piece I mean there's so much
pressure uh White is throwing it black
there's the past Pawn there's there's
the extra piece uh even if you try to
play this let's say Bishop T5 you can
even play D6 and start pushing the pawn
right away because the Rook cannot be
captured if the Rook is captured Knight
F6 check again you hang the black queen
so there is nothing abdusato can even
try here and uh exactly because of that
he resigned on move 38. uh so yeah big
congratulations to Magnus on this
spectacular achievement winning
absolutely everything
um uh I'm sure he is very happy about
that uh as we have covered mostly his
game says he's been doing well uh both
in in Blitz and Rapid so uh We've uh
pretty much uh been sticking around with
his games if you have any other game
that you've enjoyed like the ones we've
shown from from dubo from uh you know
some very very enjoyable games do use
hashtag suggestion and we're gonna uh
cover them most likely tomorrow maybe
even today but most likely tomorrow so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and this very short coverage
of the world rapid and Blitz
Championship I would like to thank
Michael zacadas Chris Mullen Leonard
static John Henry and Rafael Zamora for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day